hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll the big news
I suppose is that in fact I have given
in to social pressures and cut my hair
just a little bit I mean it wasn't even
social pressures I was not getting a lot
of social pressures it was internal
pressure part of me I will confess like
had this romantic idea that one should
just not get ones haircut during the
lockdown during the quarantine as a
statement of I don't know solidarity or
something like that
but there's a certain kind of hair
growth that leads you to be kind of
casual and rakish then there's a certain
kind that at some point you just look
like a mess you just look like a slob
I think I had crossed that threshold a
little bit so tiny bit more tidy today
otherwise we're continuing on this is
the Q&A video for idea number 10 which
was interactions remember we talked
about quantum field theory I'm not gonna
rehearse the whole thing again when we
had some free quantum mechanical fields
we showed that they were equivalent to
sets of particles and now we've turned
on the interactions a little bit and we
did scattering so basically the picture
was I will redraw this again this is
space you imagine that there is some
kind of little wave packet that
represents a particle the wave function
for a single unentangled particle that
you can derive from the quantum field
and there's another particle and they're
coming together and then over time that
evolves into something much more
complicated that we can't draw because
it's a complicated wavefunction of many
now entangled particles but basically
there's gonna be if you observe those
particles then what you will see is if
you sorry if you observe those quantum
fields you will see a set of particles
moving out in different directions so
the left-hand side really represents the
thing that is going on when you set up
the situation in the first place the
right-hand side represents one possible
observational outcome and Fineman in the
sense of in the case of Fineman diagrams
showed us how to actually calculate this
there was stuff that happened but there
are particles that were going in and
there's some particles that are going
out okay I should draw four because I
for up there bunch of particles going
out and there were details and we talked
about the relationship of these Fineman
diagrams to the interaction Lagrangian
the Lagrangian is the way you specify
what your theory is okay in this sort of
quantum field theory way of doing things
it turns out to be convenient rather
than using a newtonian perspective to
use a Hamiltonian or Lagrangian
perspective the Lagrangian is the
easiest way to basically specify what
your fields are what your interactions
are and so from the Lagrangian you
derive some rules those rules give you
numbers attached to the Fineman diagrams
and we got a lot of good questions this
week it's interesting when you get the
questions because the questions are
often very very good and they're often
things that I read the questions say
well I really should've explained that
shouldn't I have but this is why the QA
is important because you know I'm
embedded in this stuff and I kind of
forget what is obvious what it's not
obvious even if I wouldn't have ever
said it's obvious I just forget that it
needs to be said out loud so the
questions have been very useful for
example I use a lot of Greek letters
right there are lambdas there are omegas
there are Thetas etc to me everyone
knows the Greek alphabet right isn't
this just something you learn in
elementary school but sorry about that I
actually have made hidden you know
translations so that I'm using fewer
Greek letters than the typical particle
business but I do use them sometimes
sorry about that like learning a little
bit of the Greek alphabet isn't the
worst thing in the world okay so I'm not
going to teach you the Greek alphabet
that is not part of the QA but I do
apologize for using it without without
further explanation of what the letters
are so talking about the actual
questions here's one question you know
we said that this sort of Fineman
diagram schematic thing where you have
stuff then you have particles coming out
this could be equal to set of actual
diagrams actually since the example we
looked at when we had two particles
coming out let's just do that we said
that this could be a diagram like this
plus a diagram like this plus diagrams
like that were more complicated it looks
like boxes okay plus dot dot many many
more
the nice thing the reason why this could
make any sense at all there's an
infinite number of diagrams is that each
vertex comes with a small number
attached and therefore the more
complicated diagrams count less but so
one question is what if that doesn't
quite work what if the numbers add up to
more than one remember what this is
calculating for us is the amplitude what
this is calculating for us is the wave
function psy of the final particles and
there will be a different value a
different complex number for psy for
every possible set of final particles by
which we mean not only what the
particles are but their momenta how
they're moving off the directions and
the velocities in which they're moving
through space every different
possibility comes with a value of psy
and then you square it to get the
probability the probability is sine
squared for any one different possible
final particle state so the question is
what if the numbers add up to more than
one what if psy that you get by this way
or the absolute value of psy is greater
than one what if you just take all these
diagrams each one of them has a number
what if you add up all those numbers and
you get 1.2 okay then it can't be the
case that the probability for any
particular outcome is greater than one
okay that's a greater than hundred
percent probability that this happens
well the answer is then your method
didn't work and then this idea of
Fineman diagrams was not applicable so
there's two possible ways that can
happen one is you're talking about a
regime of your theory we're using
Fineman diagrams doesn't make sense
rather this is perturbation theory as we
called it which is to say this is a way
of analyzing a problem which starts with
an answer that is known and exactly
calculable in this case just particles
that don't interact at all and then
adding in a little perturbation so that
the assumption in this entire discussion
of Fineman diagrams etc is that the
interactions are small our new
very very tiny otherwise you're not
doing perturbation theory otherwise this
series does not add up to a number less
than one these numbers should be pretty
small otherwise you shouldn't be using
this method in the first place
and that's not because you know you made
a mistake you mean it might be the case
that you're in a regime where this
method doesn't work so if you're in a
proton a proton as we told you I think
I've told you is very roughly speaking a
set of three quarks and two of them are
up quarks and one of them is a down
quark and then there are these gluons we
haven't talked about those yet I don't
think in any detail but the gluons are
holding the quarks together and so you
might imagine that there's some set of
diagrams where there are quarks
connected by gluons and indeed you can
draw those diagrams that's fine but you
can't actually do this kind of
calculation this is a scattering
calculation okay so you have three
particles or at least particles that are
far away from each other they come in
they interact and they go their own way
that's very different than what's called
a bound state calculation by bound state
we just mean literally that these quarks
are bound together in the nucleus there
is no regime in the proton there is no
regime in which the quarks are free
particles far away from each other we'll
get into more details later about the
fact that quarks have this property
called confinement they literally never
are seen all by themselves they're
always in protons or neutrons or
massan's or something like that so when
you have quarks you have a bound state
and that's a reflection of the fact that
guess what it's the strong interactions
that are keeping the quarks together and
the strong interactions are strong they
are not weak so perturbation theory
doesn't work for them now there is a
regime actually so we you know we talked
about there's a coupling constant alpha
for the fine for the fine structure
constant for electromagnetism there's
also a coupling constant for the strong
interactions as we will see later videos
there is a regime where the strong
interactions are actually weak and you
can use
perturbation theory but in this ordinary
case where you just have some quarks
sitting in a proton you have to use
other techniques these Feynman diagrams
just don't work so that's one place
that's one context in which you might
get this calculation giving you a number
greater than one and it's just because
you shouldn't have been using a
calculation like that in the first place
there's another case which is more
subtle and it's real way beyond this
sort of intermediate level discussion
that we're generally having these
lectures but I will at least mention it
you can start with a theory like let's
say the the electroweak theory you know
I mentioned although we haven't done it
in a detail that Steven Weinberg and
others in the 1960s proposed unifying
the electromagnetic interaction with the
weak interactions they use the Higgs
boson as a central idea and this turns
out to be correct this turns out to be
how the world works at the energies that
were able to probe it so there's the
electroweak theory which as I said you
need the Higgs boson to make sense of it
but we didn't discover the Higgs boson
until 2012 and there's Weinberg in 1967
proposing this theory okay so for a long
time we had this theory that was very
successful but we weren't sure that it
was right because we hadn't discovered
the Higgs boson one of the reasons why
we were pretty convinced that either the
Higgs was there or something else it was
equivalent that was just as good that
was doing the job of the Higgs was that
not only was Weinberg Theory really
successful in fitting the data but if
you push it to really really high
energies if you do calculations like
this like these Fineman diagrams in the
electroweak theory without including an
explicit Higgs boson then at high
energies you start getting numbers
greater than 1 for your probabilities
this was called in this context a
violation of unitarity for technical
reasons ok unitarity has to do with the
fact that probability is conserved in
the interactions that you're looking at
and so this fact that even though the
coupling constants were not large the
calculation you did using Fineman
diagrams gave you an answer with a
probability great
one was evidence that something was
wrong and that the thing that was wrong
was you were trying to do a calculation
the electroweak theory without including
the higgs boson
so the fact that the unitarity the fact
that conservation of probability was
breaking down was evidence two
physicists just clearly theoretical
evidence that either the Higgs boson
would be there when we looked at it in
the Large Hadron Collider or something
else would do the same job as the Higgs
boson as it turns out the simple Higgs
boson idea was the correct one but
that's the kind of thing that can be a
clue to something going on even if you
don't have direct experimental data your
theory is breaking down in a regime
where it should work so you have to fix
it somehow so that is another way that
it could break down but the basic answer
to the question you know what happens if
the amplitude and therefore the
probability is greater than one is you
something has gone terribly wrong and
you shouldn't be using these methods
either change your theory or use
different methods okay another question
was energy conservation in the
elementary vertex for QED quantum
electrodynamics the theory of electrons
positrons and photons so I what I
mentioned was so we looked a lot at
interactions like this okay where you
have an electron come in a positron come
in by the way people asked about the
arrows it's an electron and positron
coming in as time moves from left to
right but the arrow goes the other way
on the positron because the arrow is not
telling you the direction of motion for
the positron it's not even telling you
the direction of the positron traveling
through time it's telling you the
direction of electron is moving and
positrons have electron this minus one
so a positron moving this way is
equivalent to electron this going that
way that's why we draw the arrow that
way and likewise over here a minus y
plus electron coming out
positron coming out also and there's a
photon in between so we looked at
interactions like this and this is you
know just the QED version of two billion
balls scattering off of each other right
you have two balls coming in they can
scatter classically you could figure out
exactly how they would scatter off each
other what angle what velocity
quantum-mechanically there's more than
one angle but momentum and energy are
still conserved but what about the
elementary vertex that we drew so we
drew this here is the electron coming in
there's a photon going out and there is
a electron going out okay so this is
just a vertex where a single electron
pops out a photon okay so you know that
energy cannot be conserved in something
like this because the electron has
certain energy and it turns into an
electron plus a photon so there must be
more energy in the final state than
there was in the initial state so the
question is like what's going on in this
elementary vertex and the answer is this
never happens this elementary vertex
that we put together over and over again
to make real actual processes that
happen is not by itself a real actual
process that happens electrons by
themselves do not just spit out photons
so another way of saying this there's a
whole set of lingo that goes along with
this right so remember this photon here
is a virtual particle as we explained at
the end of the last video it is not a
real particle and virtual particles
don't have to have the same relationship
between mass and energy and momentum
that ordinary particles do so real
particles have a relationship which is
that the energy squared equals the mass
squared plus the momentum squared the
MOE invisible three-dimensional vector
this is the relationship that all real
particles obey and this is actually I'm
gonna give you a little bit of lingo you
don't really need but in case you run
into some particle physicists on the
street this is called the mass shell why
because remember we went back way back
when
we talked about space-time we talked
about one of the nice things about the
Einsteinian Minkowski in view of
space-time is that it was a unification
it unified space and time which were two
separate things into one
four-dimensional concept and along with
it came other things such as a
unification of energy and momentum just
like time is one number and position in
space are three numbers energy is one
number and position and momentum is
three numbers that's not a coincidence
energy is sort of the time like
component of momentum that's what energy
is in special relativity so just like
you can draw a spacetime diagram you can
draw an energy momentum diagram so this
can be the three dimensions of momentum
this can be the energy okay and there is
the equivalent of a light cone it's not
a light cone but it's a condition where
because we're setting C equals 1 here
we're setting the speed of light equals
1 in all these equations otherwise the
units would not work out okay so these
diagonal lines at 45 degrees are where
the energy would equal the magnitude of
the momentum plus or minus minus on the
other side right so the mass shell of
condition why is it called that why is
this equation called the mass shell
because if the energy is M squared plus
P squared it's always a little bit
greater than the magnitude of P so I'll
make a different color but basically
this condition y squared equals x
squared plus B squared is satisfied on a
hyperbola that looks like this this is
the line that corresponds to e squared
equals M squared plus P squared for some
fixed value of M it could also be
negative but we're assuming that the
energies are positive okay so that's the
mass shell and it sort of looks like if
I you know if I could do a better
three-dimensional drawing I would fill
it in up here in a sort of smooth
rotation surface of rotational symmetry
okay and that kind of looks like a shell
maybe I don't know that's what it's
called that's it's called the mass shell
there we go
that three dimensional sorry
yeah three-dimensional three-dimensional
hyperboloid in a four dimensional space
is known as the mass Channel and why I'm
doing this why I'm mentioning all this
is not just to give you a little bit of
lingo although that's always fun but
also to emphasize the fact that virtual
particles don't live on the mass Channel
virtual particles do not have this
relationship between energy and momentum
they have some energy and they have some
momentum but this virtual particle here
this photon it's it's energy momentum
are just fixed by the fact that it is
the combination of this electron and
positron as they come together okay so
they're not real they're virtual that's
okay they do not obey this math shell
condition etc etc in this diagram right
here
the primary vertex the fundamental
vertex out of which we make all of the
other QED vertices or diagrams there is
no way that all three of these particles
the electron coming in and the photon
the electron going out they cannot all
simultaneously satisfy this mass shell
condition they cannot all simultaneously
satisfy a squared equals M squared plus
P squared for all three of these
particles so these three particles
cannot all be real particles so energy
is conserved at a vertex like this but
this vertex does not represent by itself
any actual physical process it can only
be part of a bigger diagram it cannot be
an entire Fineman diagram all by itself
okay so that's a great question as a
very important point the energy
conservation means that if you have some
energy and momentum coming in the total
energy momentum coming out is equal to
that so it's divided up in some way
that's what energy conservation means
and that can't be satisfied for real
particles in a diagram like this good
I'm glad I got a chance to explain that
all right here's a trickier question
when does the waviness of the quantum
fields waviness how should you spell
waviness waviness
really matter this was a good question
so what this means I'm not sure if
that's a very readable writing that I
have there oops
waviness what this means is you know we
started by saying we have some fields we
quantize them they were free fields and
we found that they look like particles
then we sort of made them not quite free
fields and we let them interact which is
very important but we said as long as
the interactions are weak they still
were kind of particle like that's what
enables us to do
Klieman diagrams and all that stuff but
the the implicit message by me making
those very careful statements over and
over again was that there could be
contexts in which they are not like
particles right we wish the waviness
really matters so it turns out that
there are it's a number
there are a number of contexts in which
the waviness really matters in which the
quantum fields really are fields they
are real they're not really we can't use
the particle language to talk about them
they really are always fields but
sometimes we can pretend they're
particles and sometimes we can't so
there's a number different contexts so
for example inflation we're gonna jump
way ahead this is not something that is
crucially important did level we're
talking about right now but inflation is
an idea in cosmology it has nothing to
do with economics right now this is an
idea that in the early universe there
was an energy density driven by some
scalar field right we've already talked
about scalar fields in fact we've talked
about scalar fields with a potential so
we we talked about the potential looking
like a simple harmonic oscillator right
y squared but the potential for a scalar
field V of fine oops deifying as a
function of Phi could in principle be
anything scalar fields have some
potential energy function so let's
imagine that it kind of looks like that
right why not and this amount of energy
this is the amount remember the
definition of the potential energy is
the amount of energy you have other than
your kinetic or radiant energy
it's the amount of energy you have just
by virtue of the value of your field not
on how your field is changing from place
to place so you could have a field that
has potentially an enormous amount of
energy no pun intended and what it would
do what this field would do is kind of
like a ball rolling down a hill the
field really acts like this is the
potential and so it would roll down the
hill like that and if this potential is
sufficiently flat it will roll slowly
and so this energy the energy in its
potential stays almost constant it
decreases but it decreases slowly so
it's almost a constant amount of energy
so what we're saying here is this scalar
field if it takes a value up there on
the potential can have an almost
constant and potentially quite large
contribution to the energy density of
the universe almost like almost exactly
like the vacuum energy that we have
today but because we're just making this
theory up this can be an enormous li
larger amount of energy and then it can
go away right like once it goes down
there the energy might be very small so
the idea of inflation is in the early
universe this is exactly what happened
you had some scalar field it had some
potential energy that was very slowly
changing and you can plug in the
equations for from Einstein for the
expansion of the universe and then
approximately constant energy makes the
universe expand exponentially expand
very very fast that's the phenomenon of
inflation and then you roll down the
hill then you convert into other kinds
of energy through Fineman diagrams your
scalar field decays into quarks and
electrons and photons and stuff like
that so that's the story of inflation
none of that was expressible in terms of
Fineman diagrams okay none of that is
even a story of particles particles
you know remember go back and keep in
mind the discussion we had of why
quantum fields can be thought of as
particles at all we said to start with
free fields take a wave function of
those free fields look at it mode by
mode individual wavelengths individual
wave vectors okay and then we said the
height
of that mode could have different values
which feeds into once you quantize it
different energy levels as if each mode
acted like a simple harmonic oscillator
so all that makes sense when you're very
very close to empty space right when you
just have a tiny amount of fluctuation
around the lowest energy state it looks
like you have a couple of particles and
they're freely they're not really
interacting once you have a lot of
particles and they're falling on top of
each other all the time then ignoring
the interactions between them is no
longer a very good approximation right
and once you have a field that is way
far away from its minimum energy state
again thinking of it as small
fluctuations above the minimum energy
state is not a very good approximation
anymore so when you talk about inflation
you talk about a scalar field being on a
potential and rolling down and making
the universe expand the field ness of
the underlying quantum field is
absolutely crucial you really need to
take it into consideration and put it
front and center that's one example but
you know what look there's another
example which we already talked about
the proton okay inside the proton the
quarks are on top of each other they're
interacting all the time the idea of
particles taking the quantum field and
turning into particles we did it
carefully for the case where
interactions were completely turned off
and the point was what 5 min and others
showed Heisenberg and other people
showed is that if you turn the
interactions on a little bit that
language still works the language of
treating the field as particles works as
long as the interactions are kind of
faint kind of weak you can put them back
in using perturbation theory and
calculate their effect but mostly you
could ignore them think of Galileo
dropping balls off of the Leaning Tower
of Pisa right if the balls are different
masses but approximately the same size
so you know a ball made of wood and a
ball made of steel so their air
resistance is similar etc you can
approximately ignore the air but if you
dropped a cannonball and a feather off
the Leaning Tower of Pisa you could not
ignore the difference in air so
this perturbation theory approach only
makes sense when the interactions are
weak and rare also right not just weak
but not important for most of the
lifetime of the particle here in a
proton the quarks are right on top of
each other they're interacting with
others strongly and you really have to
take the field Mis into consideration
you cannot treat them as small
perturbations of freely moving particles
and in fact it goes deeper than that
there's I'm not sure how deep we will
get but there's a wonderful story in
quantum field theory about the topology
of the quantum fields the fact that
quantum fields can wind around each
other in interesting ways that's
something that makes zero sense from the
particle point of view but is absolutely
crucial from the field point of view so
there are plenty of examples of cases
where the waviness where the field mists
of the underlying fields really does
matter where the particle description
doesn't work very well and that actually
leads right into the other question that
is related to this that I wanted to
answer you know when a decay happens
think of a decay of a particle so we did
we didn't really do two K so we did this
fundamental vertex where the electron
spits off a photon but as I just said
this never happens in real life all by
itself
it can only happen as part of a bigger
diagram so let me show you an example of
a diagram where something can happen
where a particle can decay so only one
particle coming in this will be a muon
muon is like a heavier cousin to the
electron so it basically has all the
same properties as the electron has as
negative charge it has the same flipped
on number and so forth but it's heavier
it's a little bit more massive and what
that means is it can decay so I'm gonna
give you some info here that is more
than we've covered but that's okay if
the Q a we can be more casual we don't
need to be building things up piece by
piece and what can happen is the muon
can emit a particle called a W boson so
this is a negatively charged mule on so
it emits a negatively charged W boson
the W boson is actually heavier
then the muon okay so this is another
virtual particle this could not exist as
a real thing and in doing this the muon
turns into a neutrino a neutrino is the
Greek letter nu that's the Greek letter
mu sorry about the Greek letters there
this is a mu the neutrinos are nu the
Greek letters and neutrinos come in
different flavors associated with
different kinds of leptons as we call
them so there's an electron neutrino a
muon neutrino a Tau neutrino and what it
means is when you have a muon and it
converts into something else that will
always convert into a muon neutrino
again none of this is anything you need
to know I'm just trying to give you a
real world example of the phenomenon I
want to mention this needs to be just
like the photon coming out of the
electron this needs to be a virtual
diagram because the muon turned into a W
boson and the W boson is heavier how can
that happen well how it happens is that
the W instantly decays into something
else so for example it can decay into an
electron and an electron neutrino so let
me get this right this is going to be an
electron antineutrino because we have
the electron this is conserved and the
total amount of electron is at the
beginning was zero so at the end the
total amount of electron is can be zero
and both electrons and electron
neutrinos carry electron this so you can
get zero total electron number as we
call it by giving you a plus one
electron number in the electron minus
one electron number in the anti electron
neutrino so if you count over here this
is way more detail than I need it for
this example
but this is muon number muon number plus
one and this is electron number in the
beginning we just have a single muon
electron number 0 this is muon number
plus 1 because of the muon neutrino also
has me 1 number 1 electron number
plus one minus one equals zero so plus
one for the electron minus one for the
neutrino remember this is not electric
charge the electron has negative
electric charge and the neutrino has
zero electric charge I'm just getting
you know pausing to get it all correct
you see the electorate let's do it this
way the electric charge is flowing down
this path charge me one number is
flowing down this path and electron
number is flowing down this path if you
like it's becoming way more complicated
than want it to be but anyway all the
numbers are conserved there's a reason
why you know if you're good at particle
physics you'll have to remember what the
muon decays into you can figure it out
just by thinking about it which I
basically just did just sort by saying
well charge is conserved electron number
is conserved muon number is conserved
there you go okay what are we doing here
why are we doing this so the point is
that forget about all the details what
we had in this sort of casual way we had
of saying stuff happens what we have is
going in and a muon coming out a muon
neutrino oops not an anti neutrino muon
neutrino an electron and an electron
antineutrino
so the question was the guy I told you
what the question is yet the question
was when particles decay when you have a
particle sitting there and suddenly poof
turns into a bunch of other particles is
there some sense in which the particles
that it turns into were inside the
particle that decayed and the reason why
I'm going through all this is to make it
very clear the answer is no they were
not inside there was no electron locked
inside the muon there was no neutrinos
locked inside the muon the muon was a
particle all by itself the way that we
should be thinking about this is in
terms of you know this casual picture
that we drew to start we drew a picture
where two particles were coming together
right in space
and the point was that the particles
themselves are vibrations in the quantum
fields and we were imagining that you
know this was an electron and a positron
those are stable particles those are
particles that will not decay all by
themselves but when they came on top of
each other then you had the two kinds of
fields vibrating in interesting ways and
that could set up vibrations and other
fields so the quantum field theory way
of thinking about particles interacting
is just a language for talking about
fields being on top of each other and
changing each other's vibrations okay
the same thing can happen if you just
have a single particle so if you have a
single particle like this is the muon a
muon is not a stable particle it and
basically very roughly speaking again
this is probably getting ahead but how
do you know if a particle is stable or
not well you have these quantities that
are conserved like electric charge like
electron number like muon number and
particles that are heavy want to turn
into particles that are lighter in fact
this is actually secretly an expression
of the second law of thermodynamics you
know this is one particle turning into
three there are more ways for particles
to be in collections of three than for
particles to just be one so by having
the one particle decay into three it
increases the entropy of the universe
there are more ways for that to happen
so when you have a heavy particle it
will try its best to decay into a
collection of lighter particles it can
decay into even heavier particles
because that would violate energy
conservation sometimes it cannot even
decay into lighter particles because it
would violate something else charge
conservation or muon number or something
like that the proton as far as we know
is a stable particle even though it's
heavier than the electron and so forth
you might say why can't a proton decay
into a positron an anti-electron that
would conserve electric charge but it
violates something called baryon number
proton is a baryon it has a conserved
quantity also so that's why I can't
decay but the muon it's very happy to
decay the muon can turn into these other
particles but it really is converting
into these other particles
okay the muon does not have an electron
and neutrinos locked up inside it what
it's doing is it's a field it's
vibrating and it can set up vibrations
in those other fields
so this muon turns into three particles
going their own way
two neutrinos and one electron and it
satisfies all the conservation laws so
basically it's just how long does it
take for the vibration in that muon to
be observed to be converting into these
other vibrations if you were truly
quantum mechanical if we were not if we
weren't sort of locked in our classical
intuition all the fields are always
vibrating but when you observe it it's
just like when you observe any other
wavefunction you're going to get an
answer when you observe it so when you
observe the particles it will either
look like a muon or it will look like an
electron into neutrinos okay really it's
always a combination of both it's a
superposition because we're doing
quantum mechanics but when you make that
observational measurement there's a
probability we'll get one answer versus
the other
so no they're not different constituents
locked inside the decaying particles
it's just bringing to life other
particles by interacting with their
underlying fields good that's a very
important thing okay two more little
topics that are kind of fun
one is locality because and this is this
is a fair cop someone caught me on this
I think because I was a little bit
ambiguous talking about locality
remember we first talked about locality
in the context of Newtonian mechanics I
think when we talked about space if you
go back to the video about space and we
talked about the fact that well we
talked about the Hamiltonian point of
view on fundamental physics I won't
write it here but the Hamiltonian is a
is a perspective that says that
positions and momenta are both equally
fundamental but you can derive the
equations of motions and one of the
equations of motion says momentum equals
mass times the velocity okay so that's
how velocity relates to this fundamental
thing we call the momentum but clearly
space and
Menten location and momentum are
different we think that we live in space
we live in position space nobody thinks
we live in momentum space and we said
well the reason why is because space is
the set of variables in terms of which
interactions appear local billiard balls
bump into each other when they're at the
same point in space they don't bump into
each other when they're the same
momentum in any sense so even though the
formalism of Hamiltonian mechanics puts
a position and momentum on an equal
footing the real world treats them
differently because of what the
Hamiltonian the real world actually is
in the quantum field theory or even
classical field theory context you know
if you have some Hamiltonian we write
the Hamiltonian in principle as a
function of positions in momentum but
for field theory the Hamiltonian is
going to be an integral over space of
something called the Hamiltonian density
which is going to depend on the field
and the momentum conjugate to that field
okay and these are just to be super
duper duper clear these are both
functions of space so what I mean by
this is Phi of x equals the field the
actual value of the field so is the
field configuration and that is
analogous to X in a point particle where
as pi of X is the field momentum and
that guess what is analogous to the
momentum of a point particle so we have
a Hamiltonian density which is a
function of the field and its conjugate
momentum and then we integrate it over
space so remember we said it is not
something like h equals an integral d3x
d3y of you know phi of x times pi y that
would be some weird thing where the
field at one point in space and its
momentum at a different point in space
were interacting with each other that is
not what it is that it's not what
happens the field and its momentum were
the field
self-only interact at the same point in
space that is locality in the context of
field theory whether quantum or
classical the field interacts with
itself or other fields only at exactly
the same point in space that's what
locality means in that context
now there's another context in which we
talk about locality which is the spooky
action at a distance right remember
Alice and Bob and they're entangled
particles so Alice and Bob can have a
wave function for two entangled
particles that look so like one over the
square root of two times two particles
up spins up plus two spins down and then
we know that if we measure Alice's spin
and it's up
Bob's spin will instantly be down or
vice-versa sorry the way I wrote it here
if we measure Alice's spin up we know
the Bob's spin is gonna be up and they
likewise four down okay and that's true
even if the two particles are very very
far apart so that is what Einstein
didn't like he said it's spooky action
at a distance
etc but so in my book something deeply
hidden I gave names to these two
different kinds of things I said that
there is dynamical locality so in other
words when you have the equations of
motion whether the classical equations
or the Schrodinger equation the
equations of motion for the wave
function or for the fields that make up
the wavefunction are local and that's
what is encoded in this fact that the
Hamiltonian is a function of space not
different points in space interacting
with each other but you have measurement
nonlocality
and that's what Einstein was complaining
about so this is just as true in quantum
field theory as it is in point particles
or spins or qubits or whatever in
quantum field theory you can in fact
have things that are entangled with each
other and therefore when you make a
measurement at one point in space you're
going to be able to say something about
what's going on at another point in
space far away that's the nonlocality
of the measurement process in quantum
mechanics remember the
we first talked about quantum mechanics
we said there are rules for what the
wavefunction does when you're not
looking at it and there are rules for
what the wavefunction does when you look
at it so the point is all this song and
dance about locality in field theory is
all in reference to what the
wavefunction is doing when you're not
looking at it the dynamics of the wave
function under the Schrodinger equation
when you look at it when you measure it
there's just as much nonlocality in
quantum field theory as there is an
ordinary quantum mechanics it's exactly
the same story so there's nothing
different here in quantum field theory
from ordinary quantum mechanics in both
cases you have the dynamics of the
things when you're not looking at them
which obey some principle of locality
interactions happen when things are at
the same point in space and you could
have nonlocality because of quantum
entanglement both things are true so
typically I will admit people who talk
about locality don't tell you whether
they're talking about dynamical locality
or measurement locality ok so if you
talk to someone whose interest is in the
foundations of quantum mechanics and
they say quantum mechanics is non-local
they mean that there's measurement non
locality Bell's Theorem EPR correlation
things like this if you talk to a
quantum field theories who says physics
is local what they mean is that it's
dynamically local they're not really
carrying about the measurement problem
as much so both are true they're just
different words they're sorry they're
the same word for two different things
all right last thing I wanted to mention
is the number of degrees of freedom this
is an interesting question that was
brought up in the questions in a quantum
field theory how many degrees of freedom
are there degrees of freedom or just
things you need to specify to tell me
what's going on that's what a degree of
freedom is it might correspond to some
physical thing like the position of this
particle is a degree of freedom or might
be more abstract there's just some
quantum mechanical degree of freedom
that goes into specifying the state of
the physical system well in quantum
field theory the answer is clearly
infinity there are an infinite number of
degrees of freedom but it's still an
interesting question to address because
there are different sources of infinity
so let me be clear here there's an onion
interesting sense of infinity in this
case which is if you just have infinity
times infinity or infinity plus infinity
you still get infinity okay that's what
you're gonna get one way or the other
but it's not any bigger infinity plus
infinity is the same infinity that you
had when you added the two infinities
together there's a whole complicated
well not really complicated but subtle
and careful mathematical analysis about
how big different kinds of infinities
are there are more real numbers than
there are integers even though they're
both infinitely big but when you add
them together you get whatever the
biggest affinity is you don't get a
bigger infinity than you started with
that's not what we're talking about here
that's how I'm gonna worry about here
anyway whether the infinities we're
talking about are discrete or continuous
etc is not what I'm interested in what
I'm interested in is why are there
infinities at all so there is actually
three different sources for there being
an infinite number of degrees of freedom
in quantum field theory and they're all
kind of important and kind of different
okay so one source of infinity is that
space is infinite that is one reason why
there's an infinite number of degrees of
freedom just imagine that you have space
and you divide it up into little sub
regions okay and you have you can
remember we said in in one of these
videos I don't know I've done a lot of
videos it's in lockdown I can't remember
which video we talked about but I think
it was the Q&A for in for yeah it was
the Q&A for fields that I talked about
the entanglement structure of empty
space of the vacuum for quantum fields I
said you could divide up space and you
could say well here's what's going on in
that region of space here's what's going
on in that region I said they're
entangled etc so if I did that even if I
only had one degree of freedom per
region of space there's an infinite
number of regions of space right so
that's a sort of simple and cheap
infinity this is this would be you know
because it's large distances large
amounts of space that are contributing
this infinite number of degrees of
freedom this is what is called an
infrared diverge
if you like it's not quite I'm abusing
the notation a little bit here but this
is simply because space is big this is
like saying if I have an infinitely big
universe with a finite number of
particles per cubic centimeter I would
have an infinite number of particles
even in classical mechanics so that's a
kind of infinity but it's not a
specifically fundamental quantum
mechanical or quantum field theory kind
of infinity ok it's just because space
is big so we can say let's look at a box
let's look at a box of finite size this
is called putting a cutoff putting an
infrared cutoff on our theory we're only
gonna look at a box of finite size so
here is buy a box I just made a region
of space I don't need a physical box
you'll need to bring cardboard or wood
route or anything like that I mean just
consider hypothetically in your brain a
region of space with some fixed size
let's say L we're not gonna go in any
details here but we're gonna get rid of
the annoying infinity because space is
infinitely big by asking how many
degrees of freedom are there in a box
let's say 1 centimeter on each side okay
well guess what there's an infinite
number of degrees of freedom inside the
box and that is because there an
infinite number of wavelengths that you
can fit inside that box so I can have
you know I can fit this kind of wave
inside that box that has sort of one
full up-and-down wave from one side of
the box to the other I can also fit this
wave inside the box that does that twice
we can talk about whether or not you
want to fit half integers or whatever in
decide the box but the point is I can
just keep going I can make all sorts of
wavelengths and put them inside the box
and you can't stop me and there's I can
make the wavelength that I consider
smaller and smaller and smaller until it
goes to zero size so if I count how many
different wavelengths I can fit in the
box there
infinite number so there are an infinite
number of distinct modes in a box so
infinite number of modes in any box of
size L so that's an infinity and that is
a more interesting infinity in some
sense it's not just because space is big
this is now an intrinsic feature of
quantum field theory because it comes
from starting from the assumption that
we have an infinite number that we have
a field that is smooth and continuous
okay that that that's redundant a smooth
field that is to say a field that exists
with a different value at literally
every point in space and that space
itself is smooth so the field is defined
at an infinite number of points
therefore to decompose into wavelengths
there are an infinite number of
wavelengths and this I say is more
interesting because here you might begin
to doubt that you actually believe what
quantum field theory is telling you
right we haven't added gravity into the
game yet but when we do add gravity and
there will be something called the
Planck length after Max Punk the German
physicist who used his new concept of
nature to make these fundamental units
of energy in mass and time and so forth
without gravity if gravity is not
important to Newton's constant does not
appear in the game and you can't make
the Planck length you can't construct
that number without Newton's constant so
if you're just doing quantum field
theory without gravity which is what
most quantum field theories do right all
particle physicists they just ignore
gravity there's no such thing as the
Planck length and quantum field theory
by itself extends down to arbitrarily
small wavelengths down to zero
wavelengths and remember wavelengths are
inversely proportional to energy right
you know very roughly speaking the
energy of a mode goes as 1 over the
wavelength I say very roughly because
there are two PI's I'm not going to get
right so modes become higher and higher
energy as their wavelengths become
shorter and shorter and there are an
infinite number of them that you can
talk about but you might suspect that
once you include gravity once you admit
gravity exists in the real world this
infinity might go away right this might
be an artifact of taking quantum field
theory seriously in a regime where you
shouldn't be taking it seriously so
that's why it's a more interesting
infinity because it's a little more
problematic it's a little bit less
certain that it exists in the real world
I mean there's the formalism of quantum
field theory that we use to do
calculations and we trust in a certain
regime but then there's what happens in
the real world outside that regime okay
in quantum field theory says what
happens but it might not be right
it might not be correct so this is an
infinity this is a source of an infinite
number of degrees of freedom that may or
may not be part of the real world so you
could say okay let's put a so consider a
smallest wavelength in other words let's
just say by hand that we are only going
to consider wavelengths between what
should we call it
you said lambda we used L yeah I used
all the good letters K I don't know K
this is a wavelength okay and it is the
smallest possible wavelength so all real
wavelengths are between the size of the
box and this tiny little number K so in
other words I'm now considering a box
which has a size L across my boxes are
getting worse and worse but there's also
sort of a smallest possible sub box
inside okay and this has size K across I
heard yous K because K is what we used
for the wave number right what is the
number that we haven't used yet hijk J
there you go J and people usually just
use subscripts for this but I'm trying
to avoid subscripts as much as I can so
there's a I'm just inventing this this
is not part of quantum field theory I'm
just saying let's contemplate what
happens let's contemplate when we have a
smallest wavelength we will allow
ourselves to contemplate maybe it's the
Planck length but we're just being
open-minded we're saying there's a
smallest possible wavelength and there's
a largest possible wavelength because we
have a box that we're considering so you
might think now that there's a smallest
wavelength and a largest wavelength
there's a finite number of wavelengths
that I need to consider inside the box
therefore there are a finite number of
degrees of freedom but that's wrong
that's still wrong because there's a
third source of the it's a third
infinity which is that each mode is a
simple harmonic oscillator right or is
mathematically equivalent to a simple
harmonic oscillator and what that means
is just to be SuperDuper clear here pick
a mode of a certain wavelength certain
fixed wavelength let's say this one okay
so that is a wavelength smaller than L
but larger than J so the wavelength here
is this okay starting from here and
going back to the same point so this is
allowed wavelength therefore isn't
allowed mode but what we showed is that
the quantum mechanical description of
that mode is equivalent to a simple
harmonic oscillator which means that
that mode of fixed wavelength has a
lowest energy state it has a next
highest energy state a next highest
energy state and an infinite number of
energy states okay so every mode has an
infinite number of energy states and
that implies an infinite number of
degrees of freedom so this is a third
way how many we have here yeah a third
way in which you can get an infinite
number of degrees of freedom in quantum
field theory there's an infinite number
of places the thing could be in any one
place in any one box there's an infinite
number of wavelengths the mode could
have and for any one wavelength there's
an infinite number of energies that it
could have because it's like a simple
harmonic oscillator now this is also
something that you might begin to doubt
in the context of gravity
because if you have a box of fixed size
and you put an infinite amount of energy
in it or some very very large amount of
energy in it it will collapse to make a
black hole and black holes whatever we
might know about them black holes are
not simple perturbations of flat
space-time
okay black holes are probably not even
described by quantum field theory at all
this is why quantum gravity is difficult
and and subtle and you need to go beyond
simple minded quantum field theory to do
quantum gravity so you can put another
cutoff you can put an energy cutoff
which was sort of invented by jacob
bekenstein the bekenstein bound this is
he phrased it in terms of an amount of
energy but it's the same basic idea he
said
don't include energies for wavelengths
such that the amount of energy in the
box would make a black hole there's a
cut-off there as well again we don't
know if that's true or not I mean this
is all very this is right at the edge of
what we understand in modern physics you
know we we understand this okay space
could be big let's imagine that we just
look at space piece by piece but here
for the number of wavelengths the
smallest wavelength and the amount of
energy per wavelength these are
different phenomena that only come up
when gravity is important and we know
that gravity is important but we don't
know what to do about it
we don't have the once and for all final
quantum theory of gravity so we make
these sort of haphazard guesses or we
try to invent a quantum theory of
gravity you could try to do string
theory or loop quantum gravity and say
that within those theories there are
specific answers to these questions but
we don't know which theory is right so
we don't know what the final answer
these questions are yet so anyway long
story short in quantum field theory
there are an infinite number of degrees
of freedom not just over all but even in
any one little sized box and that is a
clue that quantum field theory is not
the final story that quantum field
theory is not the way that nature works
at a fundamental level I want you to be
able to hold these two ideas in your
head at the same time quantum field
theory is the best theory we currently
have of the way nature works and quantum
field theory is probably not the way
nature works this is part of this
story that I've said before that we're
in a situation where we have theories
that fit the data really really well but
are not the final answer
that's why physics is not done yet
that's why we have to keep going that's
why it's important to inspire new
generations of young people to think
about these big ideas because I'm
optimistic that eventually we will
figure this stuff out